à tahiti l'époque du tournage des
révoltés de la bastille semble bien
révolu la polynésie plus précisément
l'archipel des marquises s'apprête en
effet à accueillir survivor la plus
grosse série de téléréalité américaine
l'arrivée de l'émission avec sa débauche
de moyens fasciné et inquiète les
habitants de nuku hiva réunion à huis
clos sur l'île de nuku hiva
le maire les propriétaires terriens et
les représentants de la chaîne
américaine cbs négocié les termes d'un
contrat portant sur des millions de
dollars la petite île de l'archipel des
marquises a été choisi pour y tourner un
épisode de survival dans cette série de
téléréalité 16 participants seront
confrontés pendant 39 jours aux
difficultés d'une vie de robinson
les sommes engagées donnent le tournis
et les habitants s'inquiètent de devoir
abandonner leurs valets aux équipes
américaines pendant une durée
contractuelle de trois mois qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont laisser pour nous où ça peut
voir les deux ak oui après leur émission
c'est ça la grande question qui se pose
actuellement c'est que qu'est ce que les
américains vont nous laisser s'est réuni
ce soir et toutes les familles pour
justement pour discuter sur le contrat
qu'on signera demain
aucune décision n'a été prise jusqu'à
présent et tous attendent la visite
aujourd'hui du président du territoire
gaston flosse afin de débloquer la
situation
en attendant les vingt maisons en
préfabriqué qui devrait abriter la
logistique américaine se construit ça la
vitesse de l'éclair
les entrepreneurs polynésiens et la main
d'oeuvre locale n'iront pas s'en
plaindre
quant aux marquisien ils ont encore du
mal à croire que le gagnant de l'épreuve
recevra la coquette somme d'un million
de dollars
tout ça pour quoi pour avoir finalement
vécu trente neuf jours le quotidien d'un
marquisien